Hello. This is 6 Minute English
from BBC Learning English.
I am Neil.
And I'm Beth.
Do the names 'Lion's Mane' or
'Turkey Tail' mean anything to you, Neil?
Lion's Mane and Turkey Tail?
Sounds like things you might find
in the zoo.
Oh, good guess, but they are actually
the names of mushrooms. Lion's Mane
is a white, hairy mushroom found
across Asia and Turkey Tail
is a brown fan-shaped fungus which
looks a bit like, well... a turkey's tail.
But if you haven't already heard
these names,
you probably will soon,
because these mushrooms
are becoming popular as medicine.
Throughout history,
our ancestors used mushrooms as food,
but also as medicine for physical
problems and mental illnesses
like depression.
In the 21st century,
this medicine is being rediscovered
and marketed. Today
mushrooms are big business.
In 2021
the global medicinal mushroom market
was valued at 26 billion dollars
and growing.
But, how real are the supposed health
benefits of mushrooms? In this programme,
we'll be finding out along
with some useful new vocabulary.
But first,
I have a question for you, Beth.
Neither plant nor animal, mushrooms
are mysterious and amazing things,
but which of the following statements
about mushrooms is actually true?
a) most mushrooms are poisonous?
b) some mushrooms can
fly? or c)
some mushrooms glow in the dark?
I think some mushrooms glow
in the dark.
OK, Beth. We'll find out if that's
true at the end of the programme.
Scientific researcher Dr.
Emily Leeming has been studying
the medicinal properties of mushrooms
for King's College London.
She shared her discoveries with
Sheila Dillon presenter of the BBC
Radio Four programme,
'The Food Chain'.
So, I think these mushrooms are
very much having a moment
right now. They're kind of labelled
as 'super brain drugs',
so, things are gonna
potentially help with lessening anxiety,
improving potentially depression.
It's very much about these mind
benefits that we're seeing the labels
on the claims getting put out there.
What do you think of those claims?
I think that at the moment
they seem to be quite overblown.
We don't have as much evidence
on humans at all.
It's very limited.
Dr. Leeming says that right now
medicinal
mushrooms are having a moment.
If something is having a moment,
It's very popular or fashionable
at a particular time.
Mushrooms are popular
due to the claims
about what they can do for example,
reduce depression,
a claim is a statement
that something is true
although it cannot be proved
and others might not believe it.
Dr. Leeming thinks some
of the claims made about mushrooms
are overblown, exaggerated to seem
more significant than they really are.
The problem is that to sell something
as medicine,
you need scientific proof
of its benefits.
You might feel less stressed
after drinking chamomile tea,
but that doesn't mean,
you can legally call camomile
a medicine,
even though it has been used
for centuries to help people relax.
However, that hasn't discouraged
many from experimenting,
especially young people.
Emma Clifford works for
Food Research Organisation Mintel.
Here, she discusses young people's
attitude towards mushrooms for BBC
Radio Four programme, The
Food Chain:
Lots of people absolutely
want there to be
scientific proof for health claims
on food and drink
because there still is a fair amount
of scepticism, distrust
and general confusion
around functionality.
However, I also think that
for many consumers
the medicinal properties
of certain ingredients,
based on natural and holistic ancient
wisdom may be just as compelling,
if not more so, than knowledge based
on modern science and clinical trials,
and I think many people,
young people in particular,
they're just really intrigued
to give these ingredients a go.
People want
scientific evidence that what
they are taking is good for them.
But many are also convinced by
ancient wisdom,
a phrase referring to knowledge,
philosophy and beliefs that existed
before the arrival of Christianity
in Europe. Ancient knowledge about
medicinal plants has been kept alive
and some trust this wisdom
more than modern medicine.
Young people are especially prepared
to give mushrooms a go.
If you give something a go,
you try doing something to see
if you like it.
They are intrigued about mushrooms -
they find them interesting and want
to know more, which is not surprising,
given some of the amazing things
mushrooms can do.
I think
it's time to reveal the answer
to your question, Neil.
I guessed one of the amazing things
some mushrooms can do is glow
in the dark.
That was, Beth,
the correct answer.
About eighty species of fungi
are bioluminescent meaning
they really do glow in the dark.
OK, let's recap the vocabulary
we've learned in this programme,
starting with 'having a moment' -
a phrase meaning to be popular
or fashionable at a particular time.
A 'claim' is a statement
that something is true or a fact,
although it cannot be proved
and others might not believe it.
The adjective 'overblown' means
exaggerated to seem bigger
or more important than it really is.
In Britain, the phrase 'ancient wisdom'
describes Pagan knowledge,
philosophy and beliefs that existed
before Christianity.
If you give something a go,
you try doing something to see
if you like it.
And finally, when someone is intrigued
by something strange or mysterious.
They're very interested
and want to know more.
Join us next time for more new,
useful vocabulary here at 6 Minute
English. Goodbye for now.
Bye.